this week on the climate show how
hooking up our neighborhoods to communal
heating networks could help bring down
our emissions as well as our bills
[Music]
hello and welcome to the show this week
amongst much else we're looking at heat
networks how communities around me are
linked to the power station beneath me
and how this idea is gaining traction
across many communities and could help
reduce climate change emissions also on
the program burning wood for power why
one of Britain's power generators may
need to rethink its renewable claims
no rain in Spain a scorching spring Heat
Wave sends alarm bells ringing Extremes
in California the once drought-start
State now bracing itself for flooding
after record snowfall and we'll hear
about the pioneering conservation
project helping lion numbers to recover
in parts of Kenya
but first green heating for our homes is
a hot subject with hydrogen and heat
pumps dominating the debate but I've
been hearing about another option which
we could be seeing a lot more of
this is swaffen prior a village of 300
houses with some dating back centuries
an unexpected front-runner in a
renewable energy Revolution
has much in common with many rural
settlements off the gas grid and homes
that are old beautiful and energy
inefficient
all those things make it difficult to
get on the right side of the climate
Story the solution is a combination of
Innovations both heat pumps and District
Heating this is the oil tank this is how
we used to heat the home so uh
this is basically uh
redundant now in December Mike severed
the oil pipe since he had hooked up to
the district heating Network there are
an estimated 1.1 million homes in
England in the same boat largely reliant
on relatively dirty and often pricey oil
and that's where the Village's Energy
Center comes in
a 12 million pound project built by a
partnership between Cambridgeshire
County Council and Bowie energy to
alleviate pollution and fuel poverty 15
homes are connected to this so far but
they're rolling out towards 300.
so we're walking through the expansion
vessels at the moment and then we've got
the air source and the ground Source
heat pumps contained in the building
their Energy Center built on Council
land contains ground Source heat pumps
fed from boreholes in the field and air
source pumps too at the moment these use
electricity from the grid but by the
summer they'll be almost entirely fed
from a nearby solar farm this is a hot
water system we're taking water here
we're taking it to 75 degrees and then
we're pumping it around the village in a
series of pipe networks to people's
homes so what's all around me here is
basically replacing 300 units in
individual homes yes basically it's much
more efficient it means that when
Technologies change and say don't know
40 50 years we only have to change the
technology here in the energy center all
the pipe Network stays in the village
and the heat interface unit is already
installed in people's homes when you've
been a bit of a Pioneer and this is the
first of its kind people are not
actually nervous they're very used to
oil so actually proving them that they
could be a different path and it's an
easy path is something that we're
working hard to do this is where all the
the new equipment is the understairs
cupboard uh mind your head so you didn't
need to change anything on the inside of
the house the radiators out there this
pipe work was all the same it's the old
radiator and hot water piping that was
already in the house and the scheme is
designed so that it can be retrofitted
into houses with minimal amount of
internal alteration do you have control
there's a thermostat that sits in the
living room and you know we can set that
like any normal heating system the idea
of District heating a central heat
source which pipes hot water to homes is
common in Continental Europe with around
12 percent of homes kept warm that way
[Music]
but District heating isn't always
attached to low carbon heat sources
here in South London rubbish is power
unrecycled waste is burned to make
electricity we process approximately
1300 tons of waste a day so this is the
combustion Grace where the waste is
processed
about how hot about a thousand degrees C
unlike most power stations which just
use that heat to create Steam and make a
turbine to make electricity this place
uses the heat as well to heat local
properties
these incinerators or energy from waste
plants as the industry prefers are big
sources of CO2 and air pollution but
they say using their waste heat which
would otherwise drift skywards improves
their climate performance
so this is the start of the district
heating Network and this is where the
hot Loop leg goes out into the local
barrel for a few kilometers and returns
back in again so this is literally like
the hot water pipe for how many homes
around here about 2 600 homes this is a
low carbon solution and it replaces the
need to have fossil fuels such as gas
used to heat those homes for the hot
water as well this you say it's low
carbon I mean stuff is still being
burned of course there is still carbon
dioxide coming off here so in what way
is it low carbon so processing wasted an
energy from waste plants displaces the
need of sending that ways to landfill so
by processing it we're actually making
use of that waste that is non-recyclable
they have plans to join up a further 18
000 homes locally as they still have
heat to spare but that does mean digging
up the streets and agreement from the
council
District heating provides about two to
three percent of heat for UK buildings
at the moment the government Target is
that it should reach about 18 to 20
percent by 2050 so about 10 times the
amount but also it could be more most of
Europe's District heating systems have a
fossil fuel at their core and here the
government's recent promise of 220
million pounds for heat networks wasn't
limited to funding those based on
Renewables one of the great things about
District heating is that whilst they can
use high carbon fuel sources a lot of
them are on gas CHP at the moment you
can then transition them by changing
just the energy center and then use the
same pipes and the same heat to the
house but from a low carbon source
networks are more efficient than a
boiler in every home and those with a
renewable Hub are very climate friendly
using a not wasting heat from existing
fossil fuel power generators has to be
positive but questionable as a
justification for their expansion
now as you've heard their waste to
energy plants like this one are making
green claims despite still having pretty
high carbon emissions
but the power station Drax goes further
it burns wood for energy and says that
is renewable but as Victoria Seabrook
has been discovering its own advisors
are saying they might have to call time
on that claim
these domes may look unassuming but
what's inside fuels controversy
wood pellets that are burned to create
electricity
in theory that's renewable because new
trees grow in their place absorbing any
emissions but the science is hotly
contested
now the UK's largest provided Drax has
been told by its own scientific advisors
to stop calling biomass carbon neutral
Drax has been running for for a decade
and the whole the premise on which Drax
was converted to biomass and bioenergy
and the basis on which it's been given
government subsidies for doing that was
that that bioenergy is is very low
carbon or zero carbon and so to be
opening that question up uh now is
certainly a surprising development
the government gives strats 1.7 million
pounds a day in subsidies for generating
electricity IT classes as green
questioning that isn't going to appeal
to ministers it could mean adding more
emissions onto our tally just as we're
trying to cut them putting our Net Zero
climate Target further Out Of Reach
it also makes it harder to argue for
more subsidies when they expire in four
years time
Drac says it may not survive without
them and that it's always improving its
evidence
a spokesperson said
the science that underpins our approach
is complicated nuanced and evolves and
we take our responsibility to develop
our explanation of it very seriously
biomass is useful providing six percent
of our electricity and it's flexible but
it's not our only option
there are lots of different renewable
Technologies out there that are low cost
and proven so from solar wind hydrogen
maybe as we determine that the biomass
is less carbon neutral than than we
previously thought we should be reducing
that Reliance and reducing how much
we're using biomass post 2027.
the government is working on a new
biomass strategy but with a debate
raging over the climate impact it's
under much more pressure to get it right
it may only be April but Spain has been
experiencing alarmingly high
temperatures of the sort that are
normally felt in July or August
Thursday the Mercury hit a blistering
38.8 degrees in Cordoba the highest
temperature ever recorded in the country
in April it comes at the same time that
reservoirs are at a fraction of their
normal levels after the driest March in
20 years
but with stories of wildfires and
drought in California
of flooding of record snowfall over
winter has become snowpack in the
mountains which is now starting to melt
Mammoth Lakes is a town entombed by a
snowpack three times the historical
average
in the space of several months
California has swung from severe drought
to extreme winter storms
this is what that looks like in the
mountains everything here is buried
for the skiers and snowboarders it's a
boon
but for locals it's a slow motion
disaster I just um collapsed it wasn't
even an explosion
barely a house here is undamaged
Steve's own home has become an igloo of
sorts we just now got sunlight in here
it's so heartbreaking many many
countless homes are going to take on
water over
um you know months it's like being
squeezed by an anaconda
and we kept screaming help us um nobody
cut the damn head off
people here no this is a catastrophe of
two parts and the worst is likely yet to
come
because these walls with the rising
temperatures are starting to melt
and they're sending torrents of water
Downstream
the snow-capped mountains are a Spectra
of Doom in California's Central Valley
near record rainfall has already seen
The Rebirth of Tulare Lake for the first
time in decades this was dry land
beneath the waves Acres of farmland
Tulare Lake hasn't just been resurrected
it's reappeared with a Vengeance it now
covers 30 square miles resembling a vast
Inland sea and over the next couple of
months this could grow to 200 square
miles
or whatever was planted there is is gone
it's been destroyed Bob has already lost
900 Acres of Farmland to the lake now
he's worried the Deluge from the
snowmelt could threaten his 20 000
cattle too it is very very serious this
this is an historic event we were in
such a severe drought here in California
so you know you you pray for the rain
and now all of a sudden you're praying
for it not to rain and you're praying
for it to be cool to where the snow melt
doesn't come down all at one time
this is now a design disaster Zone and
the state's Governor is under pressure
to shore up defenses there's not a
climate expert you know there's not a
meteorologist that doesn't say the
following we've never seen this at this
level of intensity in extreme do you
wonder what has to
climate change I just uh visit
California
is emerging from a decade of drought to
different extreme weather the golden
state has now become the southern state
with even more water on the way and for
people here that is a terrifying
Prospect Martha calners Sky News
California's Central Valley
another place particularly vulnerable to
climate change is Pakistan hit by
devastating floods six months ago which
inundated one-third of the whole country
well an organization still helping the
20 million people in need is the
International Rescue committee and their
president David miliband joins me now
from New York David you've just returned
from Pakistan tell me what did you see
in here
well the immediate
visible signs of the appalling floods
last summer have disappeared but the
deeper scars are still there remember a
third of the country was underwater at
last year now the floods have receded in
the vast majority of the country but 10
million people are still displaced the
economic suffering as a result of the
floods is still very much there and what
does it actually look like now the
waters receded I mean can you sort of
still see the damage and and what does
it mean in terms of people's lives six
months on so in the fields you can't see
the the harvest that was lost you can
talk to Farmers about how they lost
everything how they lost their assets
how they lost Livestock in the urban
areas there is a massive reconstruction
job it's been estimated by the World
Bank at around 15 or 16 billion dollars
just of physical infrastructure and so
as you go around the country there's
undoubtedly a sense from what people can
see that we're in a new age our they
think trying to rebuild in a way that
makes it a bit more disaster proof or if
you like climate change ready there's a
clear ambition that they adapt the way
in which they're developing but that is
much easier said than done and it's much
easier said than paid for and so the uh
thought that needs to go into what does
it mean for an Agricultural Economy to
be adapted and insulated if you like
against the climate crisis what does it
mean for the urban areas remember it's
240 million people in Pakistan what does
it mean for urban areas to be properly
insulated is a massive challenge there
was a lot of talk around the time of the
climate meeting Corp in Egypt about
about Justice and and payment for other
countries because of the climate change
that we in the rich and north have
caused does Pakistan feel like a
Justified recipient of that money to you
totally I mean they you can't have a
conversation in Pakistan without someone
saying look we're 0.5 of all Global
emissions yet we're in the eye of the
storm when it comes to the consequences
of greenhouse gas emissions for the
global atmosphere I think there's three
parts of it they want one they want help
to develop their economy in a way that
is low carbon secondly they want to
insulate their society from The Wider
effects of climate change that's called
adaptation they also say you mentioned
the word justice they also say there
needs to be preparation for the loss and
damage that comes from climate change
and there needs to be money for when
things go wrong and David what's the
situation in East Africa I've seen a
report out this week that says the
ongoing drought has been made a hundred
times more likely because of climate
change they've had five and they're on
the verge of six failed Reigns that
means nearly three years of failed rains
and that's contributed substantially
both to a loss of
um production agricultural production
um so the domestic production especially
of basic foodstuffs is down and the war
in Ukraine has made it a double whammy
because that's raised Global grain and
wheat prices a country like Somalia is
90 dependent and so organizations like
the entire rescue Community we're
actually on the front line now in in
Somalia in parts of Ethiopia in parts of
Kenya as well where the climate crisis
is contributing to a food crisis which
is contributing to a malnutrition crisis
well sobering news about how climate
change is affecting millions of people
there and David mentioned the drought in
East Africa and after the break we'll
hear how that is impacting both Wildlife
particularly lions and many of the
people who share the land with them
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show now
this week saw the 30th anniversary of
the Whitley Awards now they celebrate
people protecting nature and Wildlife
right across the world with really good
community-led projects I caught up with
their Gold Award winner Shivani Bala
who's been protecting lions in Kenya and
also heard about some of the other Award
winners
this marine biologist has a passion for
protecting the nocturnal seabirds of the
Mexican Pacific Islands this
conservation leader has helped the
population of kazakhstan's extraordinary
Saiga Antelope increased 20-fold they
are just some of the wildlife Champions
receiving this year's Awards and the top
award went to Shivani Bala for reversing
the decline of lions in part of Kenya
last year was a record-breaking year
we've recorded 50 Lions within the area
we cover and it's the highest lion
number we've had since 2008 so it's
really exciting for us what do you put
that success down to it's the
communities themselves leading the
conservation efforts it's our team of
Warriors who are from that region
tracking Lions knowing exactly where
they are and communicating that message
to livestock herders to avoid those
areas it's women who are involved in
conservation as well we have a great
Mama Simba program where women are
taking the lead to decide what is best
for their land and their Wildlife they
have this cultural belief that Wildlife
belonged to them anyway what brought
people and Wildlife into conflict
particularly recently we live and work
along the spectacular river called the
iwaso Nera River but since 2009 it's
been dry it's drying up every single
year climate change climate change
definitely
river that dries up basically leads to
people their livestock and Wildlife all
converging into very few areas where
they might find a little bit of water
Lions will often be lying in those
bushes they'll come across some lost
livestock or some weak livestock it's
easy prey for lions and understandably
when lions kill cows or camels the
communities do get very upset and will
retaliate and shoot Lions I mean maybe
this is too trite but is it a bit about
making Warrior Pride male pride attached
to conserving Lions rather than hunting
lives absolutely they're very proud in
what they do we've evaluated this
program and it's really socially and
politically empowered the Warriors they
feel like they're doing something really
great for their Community with the
profile and funding from the award
Shivani hopes to train 150 Community
leaders to spread her successful
conservation techniques in Kenya and
father afield a crucial project as lions
across much of the continent are still
in great peril
one thing known to cause damage to
Nature is the widespread use of
herbicides to protect food crops but one
machine May eliminate the need to do
that Dan Whitehead has more
in the gloucestershire countryside The
Vines are budding but deep in three
choirs Vineyard there is science
underway a new method of controlling
weeds is being tested no herbicides
being sprayed or Roots dug up instead it
uses electricity each of these flaps
contain electrodes and as electricity
passes through them it completes a
circuit and the heat generated
essentially frazzles any weeds that they
come into contact with
the device root wave has been designed
in conjunction with Coventry University
the system could mean an end to
herbicides that could be damaging to the
environment and potentially our health
chemicals are going up in price all the
time where we will be 10 or 15 years
from now I can't begin to imagine we've
used glyphosate weed killer for 30 years
here and I think it's time that we we
found opportunities to uh to change from
that and move on the use of herbicides
and pesticides in the UK is in the
spotlight especially since brexit and
bans imposed in EU countries the
challenge is finding an alternative to
chemicals that work on the same scale
for Farmers we have better weed control
in fewer treatments so for an
operational point of view it's actually
easier to to manage as a farmer in
addition we don't have the issues such
as a high wind that you do with
herbicide so the farmer has more Choice
when and where to weed
the soil Association says previous
Trials of electric weed killing showed
no damage to soil biology with this
product available from the summer
blasting weeds with electric rather than
chemicals could be the latest climate
friendly alternative Dan Whitehead Sky
News in gloucestershire
now before we go just a reminder that
you can catch up on all things climate
and environment on the Sky News website
an app by scanning the QR code on your
screen right now we're off for a short
break before coming back on May the 20th
for our long summer run see you then